171 plausible burials were found as a
result of a search that actually began
in May with the help of testimony of
residential school survivors in Northern
Ontario
this is an area Cemetery grounds
associated with former residential
schools Saint Mary's in Kenora there
were only five marked graves in that
area now St Mary's residential school
operated between 1897 and 1972 and
during that time more than six thousand
indigenous children went there records
given to the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission indicate that 36 children
died during that time but many
residential school survivors believe
that number was actually much higher now
the investigation into what happened
here and the discovery continues but we
know that unmarked Graves have already
been found in former residential school
sites across Canada including in the
Northwest Territories British Columbia
Alberta Saskatchewan and Manitoba here's
more from the chief of the first nation
in Northwestern Ontario
much has been done to eliminate us but
we are still here
as you grieve these findings remember
that we have survived
remember that we are still here and that
has taken our anishinaabe strength
the strength of our ancestors use that
strength
Federal and provincial ministers were
expected to be in Kenora to discuss the
next steps in this investigations the
Ontario indigenous affairs minister has
also offered his full support speaking
of support there is a 24 7 National
crisis hotline for any residential
school survivors and their families you
can see that number on your screen if
you need help I'll send it back to you